nous sommes aujourd'hui au premier
congrès des jeunes républicains qui a
lieu au touquet aujourd'hui nous sommes
au campus fondateur des jeunes
républicains au touquet nous sommes ici
pour une journée studieuse
on s'est rassemblé de la france entière
on est venus ensemble avec un bustier
partie du siège à 6h30 ce matin organisé
par la fédération de paris c'était
fondamental pour nous de venir on est
venu à une vingtaine ou trentaine même
les alpes-maritimes gouache minutes de
drancy en voiture et que trois amis à
moi dont or l'ena ornella hamel nikita
on a fait du covoiturage ensemble
c'était convivial on a rigolé on a pris
d'essai fille qu'on a posté sur twitter
et nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui
justement pour lancer les nouvelles
propositions pour notre famille
politique et notamment tout le travail
qui va être réalisé avec toute l'équipe
nouvellement élu nous avons été élus
avec geoffrey car vanino à la tête des
jeunes républicains est vraiment
aujourd'hui avec marine brenier on
voulait dire à tous les jeunes de france
nous allons vous écouter et nous allons
être à votre service et dès demain il
conviendra de travailler tous ensemble
pour être force de proposition pour nos
candidats aux élections régionales les
régionales qui sont à quelques mois on a
besoin de nous sur le terrain pour
militer on a besoin de nous aussi pour
l'unité sans importante les jeunes
prennent leur place au sein de ce parti
pour faire entendre leurs idées
chacun à sa place et tout le monde peut
présenter sa voix son énergie son
enthousiasme et son idée je pense que
c'est important que les jeunes de toute
la france se réunissent à travers des
événements parce que la politique
aujourd'hui c'est difficile pour un
grand nombre de personnes
mais beaucoup qui sont intéressés je
pense que les le fait que les jeunes
montrent justement leur intérêt et qui
veulent s'investir entouré justement par
les ténors du parti qui les soutiennent
et qu'ils encouragent je pense que dans
le contexte actuel c'est très important
et c'est bien pour la suite
on a demandé qu'on est dynamique on est
là qu il n'y a pas ce pack toujours les
mêmes têtes que la jeunesse ne l'attend
au sein du renouveau est celle où
l'avenir voilà fier d'être républicain
feared à john et montrer notre
engagement est montré que par la
jeunesse pour regagner le pays
donc la jeunesse est hyper importante
jamais mangé dire qu'elle est moteur
pour un parti parce que c'est surtout
nous qui faisons partie de ces petites
mains faisant avancer le mouvement
rejoignez nous imaginez avec nous la
france de demain une france positive
audacieuse et tournée vers l'avenir